don't just slip out before dinner with
Donn hey guys merry here to talk to you
guys about resident evil 7 now after the
lantern demo a lot of people in
comparing this game to outlast or
amnesia but Mike you got to play the
game for four hours so you would know
better than anybody I mean is it like
those games it's actually not in the
sense that it's kind of you know like
very atmospheric and its first person
it's like those games but in those games
you don't have combat really you're just
kind of hiding you're powerless it's
more about experiencing the story kind
of like you know the term walking
simulator mm-hmm residen evil 7 is very
much a Resident Evil game in fact it's
more like resident evil remake or resin
evil 2 or 3 than it is for 56 fans of
the original trilogy resonable game door
res evil zero or Code Veronica will very
much like seven um the best way I can
describe as evil 7 is resin evil remake
but in first person I mean that's
incredible because there's so many
iconic things the original trilogy did
that have been kind of lost along the
way I mean things like combat itself
right so I mean how is that like the
original trilogy yeah so just like the
originals you kind of eventually come
across a handgun early on and you know
you slowly start to solve puzzles to get
better weapons there's a shotgun and
it's kind of a you know like again
you're solving a puzzle to get that it's
not just handed to you you are managing
ammo you're combining items to kind of
manage animal like you didn't res evil 3
nemesis or combining herbs with chem
fluids to make help there's a really
cool risk/reward factor with the item
management and you know limited
inventory slots you are worrying about
what items you're gonna bring into this
basement or into that attic or oh this
boss fights coming up I'm really gonna
want to stock up on like shotgun ammo
for this how can I scour every inch of
this area to get those so overall like
there is much more survival here than
there has been since i'd say like res
evil 3 almost yeah it's it's really
refreshing to hear that even though
you're going to be getting weapons that
you might have limited ammunition that
you're gonna be making a lot of guesses
about when and where to use your guns
especially now that you've mentioned
boss fights so tell me a little bit more
about that yeah so I don't wanna spoil
these fights themselves cuz they're
actually pretty well designed there are
parts that were way too scripted which
the rest of the demo of the four hours I
played it started about an hour into the
game and then I just played straight uh
the rest of them was really good because
it wasn't scripted it was really you
know there's a sense of dread kind of
pushing me and the parts that I remember
the most vividly are things that other
people might not seem like that you know
like the term is emergent gameplay but
the boss fights sometimes got too
scripted I wasn't sure how I beat this
boss at one point or what really
happened but then you know like other
times they're really great you find a
weak spot you have stocked ammo for
about an hour now and you fight them but
yes the Baker family if you've seen um
if you played like the beginning our
demo or you saw that trailer they're
released shows you know that
cannibalistic family eating like human
organs and stuff the table could forget
right and they're the kind of presiding
clan of the estate that you find
yourself in which is very indicative of
the original resonable mansion but then
there's a greenhouse there's there's
like an old like dockside shack that you
go into on the entire time it's almost
like resin evil 3 nemesis in the sense
that before you fight a couple these
bosses they're hunting you are stalking
you for about I don't even know like in
one case i think is like half an hour so
you're scavenging but you're also
worried is this person gonna come up
right behind me when I'm not expecting
it and just bash my head in with a
shovel which happened to me several
times yeah there's like so many of those
old-school feelings that I'm getting
from this and I'm really excited about
and something that you mentioned earlier
that I am very excited to see his backer
puzzles how tough are these puzzles ah
the puzzles themselves when you're
trying to solve them most of them aren't
too difficult but in the sense that the
entire demo I played and you know like
in being indicative of the entire game
the entire game is kind of one puzzle
like you're not just going to go into
every room in this mansion you know like
in the original you're getting the
helmet key to sort key she'll key I was
getting the serpent key the Scorpion key
so like there was this one door I need
like I knew I need to go through but I
also knew that the key to get there
might be in the basement where these
crazy moulder monsters they're calling
them were just like you know rampant so
I went into the basement against my
wishes found the Scorpion key bolted out
of there and then unlocked like three
more doors that got me like you know the
shotgun for instance or the next key or
just like a really useful item that's
gonna help me later on so the overall
navigating the mansion in the shack out
side in the greenhouse and from what
they told me there I'm gonna be more
areas on this estate it's not just one
centralized house it's like an entire
plantation in the you know the American
South the entire thing felt like a
puzzle to me it was kind of like a
Metroidvania feel if you want to call it
that again very much like resident evil
resonable to resident three right you're
going past all these doors knowing that
you're going to have to go through them
at some point or going past that
basement trying to avoid it but you're
gonna have to go in there and I love
that you know it's unfortunate even
though you've got four hours you weren't
able to capture that we kind of got this
else that's what you're seeing now we
don't have a lot of b-roll of everything
not of like all the crafting and stuff
but something you did have or some of
the creepy areas you're going to like
the swamp area so like you're going into
these like really creepy areas too I
don't know fight what yeah so there are
these things in the basement at first
you see that almost if you play dressing
before will remind you of the
regenerators we had a shirt shoot where
you had to shoot specific spots in their
body or else they would regenerate these
are called moulder creatures moulders
they were kind of unclear on it you know
you just they come out of the basement
wall and attack you and the swamp the
swamp became actually I think there is
one person the entire time in the swamp
that I was that was hunting me and I had
to in turn fight later on and again I
don't want spoil too much but the amount
of enemies was not overwhelming at all I
think aside from the basement it was
always like one member that Baker family
hunting me which in a way was much
creepy to me it wasn't oh there's
probably a couple zombies around the
hallway it's like he is downstairs right
now I can hear his footsteps I don't
want to go that side of the house
because he's going to hear me and come
find me so in a way it was much more
like the sense of dread and like kind of
like in a weird way a good anxiety that
I haven't felt since I played like the
original resident evils um obviously
rising before is a very good game and I
enjoy five I don't like six but I think
Capcom in general has figured out what
made those original games great and it's
finally kind of being brave enough to go
back to that but aren't using as a
crutch because there are newer things
like the first person this new setting
which very much doesn't feel like that
corporate espionage storyline of the
umbrella umbrella chronicles
like darkside chronicles and whatnot
feels very much more grounded yeah it
seems like that's kind of run its course
and it's trying to evolve it a little
bit but going back to scorpion keys and
things like that like that's so iconic
and people will remember that and
probably in in mostly really positive
ways and the last thing I really want to
touch on is it what you've been talking
about being stalked and hunted and never
feeling safe are there any places where
you feel safe uh few and far between but
yeah there are safe rooms again they're
back they are back so you won't just be
pressing start to save you will be you
know going to save rooms depositing
items in these boxes you know getting
like i think it was i don't i cant
rember foes inc ribbons again that
you're using with typewriters but you're
saving at specific spots but you're also
like thinking in your head like I only
played before ours but the layout of
this mansion and the grounds are burned
into my brain already so I'm thinking
like this shortcut works best to get
back to that save room or like if I go
downstairs here first and then like jump
up this ledge and then use the secret
door they open through a puzzle earlier
I'll go back get back to the safe room
and I'll get grenade launcher rounds to
help me against this boss so there's not
very much more for thought this time
around and item management and puzzles
and just like learning the layout of
this Metroidvania kind of original
resonable feel game as a fan of the
series since its birth I'm really
excited that Capcom seems to be going
back to that while also introducing
enough new wrinkles into the formula to
make it interesting yeah you're making
me really excited yeah I can't wait
sounds like everything yet I would enjoy
from a Resident Evil game and to hear
all the changes but you know staying
true to that original trilogy it just
sounds so good and for everything else
resident evil and all the latest on that
game you guys are going to want to stay
tuned to gamespot
you